But as soon as we write any code that relies on the differences that
exist between a regular car and a cop car, then we have a bit of a problem.
We can't really add a cal method to every car instance because we don't
really think that non-cop cars deserve that method.
One naive solution would be to copy all of the code from the car class into
a second class and then re-factor it.
We'd probably give the two functions different names to reflect that they
are different classes.
Then in each function, we would add the code that would make that particular
class different from the other.
In this case,
imagine that the grab method is something only vans should be able to do
because it's the way in which the van is going to be able to attack the player.
By contrast, this cal method is something that's only available to cops.
Because it represents the way in which the player can get access to
help from a cop.
In this scenario we would have two different constructor functions that both
produced objects that were basically identical with the exception of this new
method, either grab or cal.
This solution works.
But as you can see, there's a lot of duplicated code here.
Let's look for a solution that allows us to reuse that code,
rather than type it twice